عائشه تخرج من رحم الركام نايف صحيح لا
ادري انقطع الاتصال يعني لكن عائشه عائشه
الان نايف الحمد لله عائشه خرجت بعد ثلاث
ساعات من محاولات الانقاذ خرجت وهي بصحه
ربما ان شاء الله في هذه تشاهد الان بعد
ساعه سته ايام عاشتها تحت الانقاذ يعني
وتم اخراج حتى اخواتها بالاسعاف تحمل
بالاسعاف الان لحظه فرح
[موسيقى]
في هذه الحاله
السريعا بسيارات الاسعاف في سيارات
الاسعاف ونقلهم الى اقرب مستشفى لتقديم
العلاج اللازم
ان شاء الله الله يعطيكم العافيه جميعا
الحمد لله الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد
لله لا ادري ماذا اقول في هذه اللحظات
يعني واضح يعني
مشاعر الفرحه والصدمه والذهول بكد لا يصدق
الصوت ونحن معك الطريقه نعم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لو سمحت ممكن بس احكي لنا نفس صوتها طلع
اعطيني صوتك وين انت قالت لي انا هون بس
[موسيقى]
جده الله يجزيكم الخير وبطلب من كل اللي
عم يشوفونا يدعينا
ايه الكرسي عليك الله يخرجها بخير وسلامه
اعاده الحياه للحظه الاخيره للحصيده
الاخيره بعد ما توفيت ابنته وفخري وحفيدتي
الصغرى الحمد لله الاثنتين بحاله جيده
[موسيقى]
عائشه خرجت من فم الموت صحيح عائشه وهي
محاولات خروج بعد ولاده عصيره وولاده
قيصريه
[موسيقى]
اتوجه بالشكر والحمد لله رب العالمين من
الدرجه الاولى وكما وتوجه بالشكر لقناه
العربيه التي قامت البث المباشر ونحن على
اعصابنا وقريبه اعصابنا كما يتوجه بالشكر
الى كل ما قال بمساعدتنا بهذه الرحله
[موسيقى]